now  [Music]  [Music]  before the cowboys of the wild west  there were hungary's chicos  horsemen of the pusta hungary's great  plane  their way of life is centuries old and  blends tradition with death-defying  riding  they are some of europe's greatest  horsemen  [Music]  are tasked with caring for the region's  horses and cattle using centuries-old  techniques  [Music]  adam's father janos has been a chikash  for 35 years the first in the family  adam followed in his father's footsteps  [Music]  the riders live in relative isolation on  ranches that dot the planes  only a few chicos are left in the region  and it's becoming difficult to keep the  ways of the horsemen alive  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you